my brother back Baris look at you o la
[Music]
la I'd like to come to Paris to Future
Adventures I will be
waiting my family keep writing to them
over and over just like I'm writing into
a
point
the Germans are already at our
doorstep it's getting
worse all of Europe is a
warm let our family be our light we live
tonight
I just want to get home you are a Jew
travor for you is a death
sentence I'm
going going I'll be coming home
soon long as I can see the light I
understand the impossibility of getting
home but we will find a way to be
together
again we must organize we've lived here
for a thousand years we know this
country this land I want to do what
you're doing but if you get caught it
jeopardizes all of us I'm aware of the
sticks you are my family we stay
together
always
faith is a
choice it's an act of
will our families are out
[Music]
there com
on all I can see
the the only thing I know for certain is
that there's no reason I should be alive
and yet I
[Music]
am and that means I have to keep
going
all